[Musica]
Come avrete notato sono l'unico dei 10
speakers in cui nella biografia è
annotata la data di nascita
1951 come per dire Portate pazienza il
più vecchio
e in effetti
l'età oltre ai dati negativi anche dei
dati positivi cioè il fatto di poter
raccontare delle storie avvenute in
tempi lontani quasi 40 anni
fa io sono nato tra le scarpe
e mio padre era capor reparto alla
Nordica di Montebelluna e mia madre
aveva un piccolo laboratorio ricavato
dalle stanze di della casa di famiglia
ma
e le scarpe di cui voglio parlarvi
stasera delle quali voglio parlarvi sono
famos in tutto il mondo da esattamente
36 anni e si chiamano Air Jordan le
scarpe di Nike per Michael Jordan La
leggenda ormai
conosciuta universalmente
la la mia prima il mia prima idea era
quella di scappare dalle scarpe perché
mi alzavo il mattino parlavano di scarpe
a pranzo parlavano di scarpe di notte
parlavano di scarpe quindi mi diplomai
come chimico tessile e il primo lavoro
fu in una filatura
poi avvenne una rivoluzione industriale
gli scarponi da sci passarono dalla
classica costruzione manifatturiera in
Pelle e Cuoio alla plastica
e mio padre che era innamorato del suo
lavoro fin dal
1958 e mi chiamò e mi disse Guarda che
non son più scarpe sono degli oggetti di
plastica con design avanzato prodotte
con macchine ad alta
tecnologia in quel periodo io ero
ufficiale dell'Esercito a Palmanova del
Friuli e mi capitò casualmente di vedere
un film di qualche anno prima Il
laureato con Dustin Hoffman E disce cosa
c'entra Il laureato con le scarpe a un
certo momento il Eh il protagonista
Benjamin che era interpretato da Dustin
hofman viene chiamato in disparte da un
amico di famiglia e nel consigliarlo eh
Che strada seguire gli dice la plastica
ben il futuro è nella plastica questa
frase mi rimase in testa per giorni
tornai a casa andai a un breve colloquio
alla Nordica e Fui assunto nel reparto
delle stampaggio delle materie plastiche
che era tra l'altro il settore più
vicino alla mia preparazione scolastica
e poi avvenne
un movimento interno aziendale e nel
quale io io venni coinvolto in quanto
come attitudine personale avevo il
design la progettazione e la e la
creatività e mi inserirono nel team
dello sviluppo
prodotto con la decisione del Management
e della proprietà di Nordica di
diversificare in diversi prodotti
manifatturieri EB l'occasione di
incontrare le tre persone che cambiarono
radicalmente la mia vita
professionale economica e anche la mia
vita di tutti i giorni e come in un film
incontrai un
killer questo signore Però
fortunatamente era di cognome Killer si
chiamava Gunter Killer inizialmente
avevo dei dei dubbi sullo spelling Ma si
chiamava come se un italiano avesse di
cognome facesse di cognome assassino e
in effetti non lo era però era quello un
killer questo signore era il manager di
una multinazionale Franco tedesca con
sede a Lione e Amburgo si chiamava
phenix Palladium
e già e produceva pneumatici soprattutto
ma aveva un importante settore
calzaturiero nella storia della loro
azienda avevano già dei contatti in Asia
con la Corea del Sud Taiwan Filippine e
Hong Kong dopo qualche mese il killer mi
disse Ma perché non lavori con noi
e Mi propose di lavorare come libero
professionista e fondare il primo studio
di design e sviluppo prodotto a
Montebelluna e così feci e fondam la
Sport Style che era il primo studio che
poi seguito da molti altri negli anni Il
primo viaggio che programmo fu Nel
1978 Come in una barzelletta allitaliana
eravamo un francese un tedesco
uno svedese e un italiano
e andamo prima in Corea e poi a Taiwan
dove visitammo la più grande fabbrica di
scarpe dell'epoca si chiamava feng thai
e produceva già Allora per la Nike
articoli iconici come la Air Force One
che ancora si vende o la tailwind da
corsa il Ecco che incontrai la seconda
persona che cambiò la mia vita
professionale e tutto il resto e CH Wang
C puntato h puntato Wang Chi era questo
signore era era nella precedente
fotografia Era il proprietario
presedente della feng Thai il quale
intravide o valutò in me la persona che
poteva dargli una mano per fare il salto
di qualità e implementare la sua azienda
che aveva Allora già 15.000
dipendenti Mi propose un contratto al
quale non potevo dire assolutamente di
no non in stile mafioso ma in stile
economico
e accettai e da lì iniziai a lavorare
con lui che praticamente produceva
esclusivamente per Nike in quel periodo
avvenne il terzo incontro e
cioè Mark Parker Mark Parker Chi era
costui era un giovane neolaureato o
meglio laureato da poco in scienze
politiche e nelle grazie di Phil Knight
fondatore di Nike il quale divenne
subito mio amico probabilmente qualcosa
sapevo fare perché mi ha detto tu vieni
a lavorare con me a beaverton in
Oregon per la Nike Ma io avevo
già avevo già gli interessi economici e
oltre una famiglia con un bambino
piccolo in Italia e dissi Guarda non
posso muovermi dall'Italia bene allora
se la montagna non va a Maometto
Maometto va alla montagna e crearono un
ufficio apposito a Treviso proprio sopra
vicino a Piazza dei signori
e sicuramente avrete o molti di voi
avranno sentito parlare del
film recente di Ben Affleck e Mad Demon
Air dove si racconta la storia della
firma di Michael Jordan con Mikey e
Quella fu la Air Jordan 1 Air Jordan
One disegnata da Peter Moore scomparso
di recente e prodotta proprio dalla feng
thai a Taiwan in quel degli anni la il
grande successo dei designer e stilisti
italiani come Gucci Valentino Ferragamo
Armani era il l'immagine che elevava
praticamente la parte di popolazione che
veniva chiamata Inner City delle grandi
città a un livello perlomeno estetico
superiore quindi Nike decise che l'ir
Jordan 2 cioè l'immediata successiva a
l'ir Jordan One doveva essere un
prodotto made in Italy e con la firma di
un designer italiano così procedemmo con
lo sviluppo prodotto nel mio studio a
Montebelluna e nel frattempo
avevamo fondato una ditta produttrice di
scarpe sportive Tra l'altro non molto
lontano da qua ad Altivole con il famoso
Killer
e e con un altro socio operativo
e dove producevamo scarpe da tennis per
iniezione diretta
con messi insieme questi due queste due
unità la Nike decise di procedere con la
produzione e lo sviluppo prodotto dell
Air jnan
2 disegnato da me in collaborazione con
un designer americano della Nike e con
il team del mio studio di cinque persone
tra cui mio fratello tra le quali mio
fratello a questo punto la
situazione partì in modo esplosivo in
quanto Michael Jordan eh apprezzò
immediatamente queste scarpe usciva da
una sosta di 6 mesi dovuta una frattura
a un malleolo e con queste che erano più
morbide con pelle più più soffice riuscì
a riprendersi
subito la più grande operazione di
marketing di scarpe Questo era il titolo
uscito in famoso giornale sportivo
americano e in effetti questa mossa
strategica di marketing
cambiò completamente l'immagine delle
sneakers soprattutto de Jordan non solo
come scarpa sportiva Ma come Calzatura
di tutti i giorni del Fashion e quelli
che noi oggi chiameremo influencers che
erano i rappers Inner City crowd i
presentatori televisivi e tutti i
protagonisti del del gossip di Allora
iniziarono a usare queste scarpe tutti i
giorni e da lì per 36 successive
versioni leir Jordan è diventata la
scarpa più famosa del
mondo la morale che posso ricavare da
questa esperienza è che Beh intanto
dimenticavo dopo qualche anno
AV Abbiam dovuto smettere per una
questione valutaria Il Dollaro in giro
di pochi mesi crollò dal 30 40 50% e la
Nike ritornò a produrre nei paesi
asiatici dove le monete delle della dei
vari paesi non Seguivano la azione del
dollaro praticamente erano legate al
cambio del dollaro
la la morale che posso trarre da questo
è che soprattutto in età giovanile
bisogna seguire i propri sogni crederci
perseverare e non aver paura seguendo
Soprattutto due linee guida che mi hanno
sempre accompagnato di due pensieri di
Albert Einstein il primo dice chi non ha
mai commesso errori non ha mai provato
qualcosa di nuovo e secondo è che la
vita è come andare in bicicletta per
rimanere in equilibrio bisogna sempre
muoversi
Grazie